I'm wearing some beat up dirty air force
ones right now hello glamor I'm India
armentifio and I am playing Actor versus
character oh me as India I'm I'm a
hopeless romantic and Charlotte is also
a hopeless romantic because we both are
quite emotional and empathic
um and probably just want to find true
love Queen Charlotte is afro for sure
and very unapologetically afro I as
India and braids purely for ease me as
India staying in Queen Charlotte going
out I love staying in I love getting
getting a good book getting my favorite
food pesto pasta Charlotte loves a ball
she loves a dance she loves going out to
the gardens chalk and cheese on that one